George Anthony devolder Santos also
known as lying Republican Congressman
George Santos has pleaded not guilty to
13 different charges related to an
investigation into alleged criminality
his immediate reaction after pleading
not guilty was to say it's a Witch Hunt
just like it is with Trump or whatever
um you know listen uh the Trump thing is
not a Witch Hunt but the Santos thing is
really not a Witch Hunt and these aren't
even really what you would call
politically related crimes although some
of them do relate to his campaign and
time in office he's got a real uphill
battle here and the question now becomes
are Republicans going to use this as an
opportunity to say now we can get rid of
him